the status symbol choice i'm dave ramsey
your host dr john deloney ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author of the book redefining anxiety
and host of the hugely popular podcast
by the same name check it out by the
name dr john alone anyway
you check it all out there he talks
about mental health and relationships
and boundaries and
all those kinds of things your life and
we're going to talk about that with you
today as well as your
money questions and anything else you
want to dig into this is all about you
and we talk about you right in front of
you the phone number is triple eight
eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two
five five two two five john's in detroit
to start off this hour
hey john how are you dave i'm good how
are you better than
i deserve what's up so i have a
unique question we uh my wife and i were
completely debt-free with the exception
of
our mortgage um we are in the process of
selling our construction business
and we're going to use the profits of
that to pay off the mortgage
and then we're not too certain how to
handle the rest of the money we have
about
i'd say about a 65 000 emergency fund
saved up and beyond there
we figured grow the emergency fund and
then make some steps towards retirement
or investing but that's the
portion that we're not too clear on what
to do with
how much you're getting from the company
5 25.
i hate it when that happens way to go
man congratulations
how's that feel thank you very much
you're like running around the backyard
yelling touchdown or what
we're going to we're going to holler out
we're debt free first and then touchdown
yeah how old are you i'm 36.
way to go are you clearing any business
debt on this deal or is it just
525 depositing in your checking account
we we have no business that out of the
525 is the purchase price so
taxes are going to come out of that sure
um how much you owe on your home
uh 230 about 230. why'd you sell the
business
uh we'd like to slow down life a little
bit we have five kids
uh we're teaching them you know how to
farm and and whatnot so we're just
looking to slow down life a little bit
so what are you gonna do for a living
i will probably continue as an
independent contractor there's also some
consulting
opportunities that i've been asked about
so i'll probably
precede those as well okay so you think
you're gonna have what kind of household
income going forward
uh i'll i'll easily be able to with what
we're going to do going forward having
80 to 100
000 household income i'd like to lower
that as much as i can and supplement
our own family farm so i'd like to get
it low
as low as let's say 65 or 70. um
that's you know that'll be a change for
our family are you supplementing the
family farm why didn't it make money
well yeah absolutely we're wanting to
use that to create
uh income as well but we'd also like to
make sure we're providing
a good amount of our food and you know
produce we have cows and
pigs and chickens so we'd like to
provide a good amount of our food
uh on that as well and then what's left
definitely turn into
income living a dream way to go man so
proud of you
i'm trying to okay well there's there's
three things you can do with money
you can give it and you should you can
enjoy it
called lifestyle and you should and you
can invest it
and you should so no you do not need to
beef up your emergency fund it's
probably too big now
and based on what you told me uh you do
need to pay off the house i put you at
baby step seven the rest of the money is
left to do those three things with
invest
give enjoy now invest could be back into
the farm to get it going which is what i
think i just understood
it's not a permanent loss you're going
to buy things that are going to
create income correct
correct that's an investment that's not
a lot it's not a cost that's not
um supplementing that's investing
and then uh and if you invest into some
real estate you pay cash for
or into some mutual funds like we talk
about these are the things i
invest in um and somewhere in there
and you give some of it and you guys
enjoy some of it
um it sounds like the overall move is to
get the get your life back
um and then make sure that you're living
that you're creating enough of an income
to live on
and live that life without having to
touch those investments so after taxes
mortgage uh investing into the farm
a little bit of enjoyment that's i want
you to splurge
something just to have a woohoo moment
not a lot it doesn't have to be a lot it
could be ten thousand twenty thousand i
don't care there's something you wanna
buy i don't care what it is you you just
decide
you and your wife uh and same thing
about the generosity piece
then you can decide what how you want to
invest the rest of it but you've done it
man i mean
you nothing you're saying is wrong if
you say
i want to give all of it i'm going to go
yeah
think about that i want to invest all of
it i'm going to go yeah
think about that i only want to consume
all of it hedonistically
i'm going to go yeah think about that
but i think when you got a little of all
three in there you got a good mix
that makes sense that makes perfect
sense it sounds wonderful
and the deal is you and your wife need
to sit down now we'll tell you this you
will
mess this up if you don't treat it like
a building project 525
minus taxes minus mortgage
assign those dollars this much to
generosity
this much to uh enjoyment this much to
the farm
this much to mutual funds go ahead and
before you get the money
because all of us have had the
experience of putting money into a
checking account
and then go where'd it go it just left
sure and if you don't tell it what to do
it will run off into somebody's account
who does tell it what to do
and john let me throw more thing on
there dave just talked about the money
money part there's going to be an
existential crisis you're going to run
into in a few months
because you're a hard-working
hard-charging builder planner
scraper claw that's how you built a
company that you're selling for half a
million dollars before you're 40 years
old
and you are going to think that
everything's going to be great on the
back end because you've
done this thing if you don't have a new
mission a new purpose
a detailed plan for what your days are
going to look like your weeks your
months
where are you and your wife working
towards we're just going to
get some more time with our family
you're going to get real restless you're
going to get real annoying to each other
and then all of a sudden i've seen
families implode on each other dave when
somebody just retires without a plan or
somebody just
you know i i finally got enough money to
pay i had a friend that sold his stuff
john
uh what what john what john dolone is
talking about john
sold his business he was 32 years old he
sold it for a million and a half
and um he said i you know i've been
working since he was 16.
on that business growing it and um he
said
for the next three years i went fishing
and got fat
and he said i almost i almost died and
he said and and so what did he do
at 35 years old he went back to work
yeah because he you need to have
something to lay your hand to
so better to say i'm going to do this
consulting thing
i'm going to do this have something to
lay your hand to because
kicking your feet up in the air kicking
back in the chair sitting in the
recliner at 36
is a bad plan terrible plan it's not
what your plan is but just
to john's point you can't fish that much
you can't play that much golf you need
something to do that has meaning
and i do a little of both of those
neither one of them have meaning
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we take your questions
about your life and your money the phone
number triple eight
eight two five five two two five
life gets busy we know this between work
family summer vacations everything in
between sometimes
marriages take a back seat
and the connection with your spouse can
fade
39 years on saturday last saturday for
me
congratulations man 39 years that was
dangerously close to 40.
39 years yeah so yeah this is real
time to reconnect bring back the spark
romance fun with summer flying bites a
perfect time for a summer date night
on friday july the 16th joined rachel
cruz and dr
john dalone for the money and marriage
live stream event rachel and dr dolony
are going to
teach you how to navigate the top
challenges married couples face today
when it comes to money and intimacy
you'll learn how to get clear on what
you need from your
partner and how to the two of you can
have a better conversation build the
future you're excited about
for you ramsay plus members you've got
access to the event as part of your
membership if you're not a ramsey plus
member
early bird passes are on sale right now
for only 20 dollars
early bird prices won't last long that's
why they're called early
bird prices text marriage 233
7 89 the problem with the money and
marriage event is it's rachel
and john doing it and both of them are
funny
and so it's there's it's like a comedy
routine between the two of you
yeah she's very serious and very
intellectual comedy routine she's
uh she's reminds me a lot of my sister
and it gets off the rails pretty fast
there's usually a few people making sure
that the boat stays in the water there
yeah they're trying to keep you two
between the ditches but um
oh my gosh yeah and both of you are
wicked smart and both of you have a lot
to say about money and about marriage
and so
the overlap is fabulous yeah the
chemistry's good
and the material the content is
absolutely amazing
and one thing we know for sure having
done this show for 30 years now
almost is that
marriage and money are tied together you
cannot untie them
you cannot talk about money without
talking about marriage if you're married
and you cannot talk about marriage
without talking about money because they
they
just because your treasure is where your
heart is where you spend your money just
says so much about what's going on in
the
power structure of the relationship
what's going on in the communication
style in the relationship
we found this out accidentally years ago
making couples do a budget together
uh and what they come back and go this
is the best marriage class we've ever
had
because we dig up all kinds of stuff we
force them to
combine their value systems and they
never had yeah
the beauty of this conversation with me
and rachel is or this event
is we're both married and we're both
trying to figure out money
and so you can have all the academic
insight you want all the knowledge and
read all the studies it's a totally
different thing when me and sheila are
trying to figure out budgets
right because her childhood comes up and
my childhood comes up and what i want
and
rachel's my daughter so she had a
childhood oh my god
can you imagine being raised as my kid
you know no actually that right there is
a counseling session in and of itself
but
yeah the the uh the mental health
practitioners of america think parents
like you
for keeping us all in business but but
yeah it
um and the last one we did in february
for valentine's day we had 20 000 people
yeah on the stream it's just this it
came out from underneath
right so we're excited to do this again
um and i don't know about you guys but
this summer's just six months and can
you believe we're six months into
after 2020 yeah like it just happened
overnight and
everyone's still trying to figure out
what to do 2020 happened to marriages in
2020 happened to money
yeah both and we're all healing and
people are trying to get trying to get
the water back even again you know
and so july the 16th rachel cruz dr john
baloney the money
and marriage live stream event twenty
dollars is all it is for early bird
pricing
ramsey plus members watch for free
so well as part of your membership it's
not free but it's part of your
membership
and all you gotta do if you wanna sign
up text marriage
to 33 789
marriage two three three seven
eight nine if you can agree on your
spending
you have agreed on your future
it's a big deal if you agree to stay
married
you're agreeing to sit down and have
some hard conversations about what money
means in your house
yeah well i mean right you know it's
very expensive to end the marriage
yeah it's very i mean it sets you back a
decade or more
uh you can lose a lifetime of work in
that the old laughing the old not funny
joke is marriage is grand divorce of 50
grand
i never i've never heard that joke bad
bad joke but yeah but very true but it's
also you go uh-huh
yeah although i did have one guy call in
and i said how'd you get that free and
he was a divorce driver
well oh wow and there
there's there's that a lot of men
couples tend to when they divorce they
tend to have really divergent paths
financially about what that means for
each
each person anyway man if you're all in
stay in
join us for this event and be fun yeah
there's a lot of ways to
fix both of them and or to get better at
both of them you know who comes to this
it's not usually the people that are in
crisis it's usually the people that
are just wanting to learn so they never
face a crisis or when they face a crisis
they've got the tools how to go
get my marriage that's at a six how do i
get it to an eight yeah right
it's not i'm at a negative four uh we're
in nuclear meltdown and we think a 20
live stream is going to fix it it's not
but sometimes you sit on the couch to
watch a live stream and you think you're
at a seven
you realize oh where to where to four
four points right we need to go talk to
somebody right so eight seven five
it's good yeah it's good yeah so july
the 16th
text marriage right now and you can get
signed up text
marriage to 33 789 the
money and marriage event dr john baloney
rachel cruz it will be
fab bob is with us bob is in tulsa
oklahoma hi
bob how are you thank you dave for
taking my call i just want to thank you
also we've been
done fpu since 2003 our lives are
changed we're eternally grateful and i
want to thank you for that so much
cool my question my question is we have
a
family trust and we have three wonderful
girls
uh our seventh grandchild on the way and
so forth and
we are two of them work with us in the
business
and the other one has a successful
business with their husband in another
state about three hours away
same line of business and so forth we
are
planning on leaving and the trust is for
all three of them
but the business we're planning for the
two of them
that work with us is do you see anything
wrong with that or should the business
be left for all three
or is uh the trust is but not the
business
the way we have it right now what's your
thoughts on that the business the
ownership of the business is inside the
trust
um it is set
you know that's a great question my wife
and i were talking about that that we
just had this done
um it's it's we've separated it from
from the three yeah we had we had a yeah
well you can have a trust with three
people in it and the terms of the trust
are the business goes to two people
you can have a trust like that and
everything else is divided three ways
inside the trust you can do that as well
so i don't know how you've got a
structure it really doesn't matter so
what you're doing is fine there's
nothing morally wrong with it nothing
relationally wrong with it as long as
everybody's on board
i'll give you a couple of thought i'll
give you a thought and then a pointer
okay thought number one that we learned
early in our process
is to separate working in the business
as your career is a separate thing than
ownership
okay in other words you don't have to
work in the business to be an owner
that's true of any business by the way
you could just be an investor right
and so in our case we chose to do it
differently than you have
rachel's obviously a personality my son
daniel is
on our operating board and uh one of our
executive
senior executive vice presidents uh
running a whole section of this business
today
uh my daughter denise does not work here
like you're like one of your kids uh in
our case the kids
own the business one-third each
and are paid for their one-third each as
an owner off the owner line
the other the two that work here
rachel's paid like john
deloney's paid off the personality line
and daniel's paid
like our other senior executive vice
presidents so they get paid for their
job
but then the ownership is different
that's owning stock
in the company you can separate those
two and you haven't
so that's a thought the if you want to
keep it like it is it's just fine
there's nothing wrong with what you've
done
the pointer i'll give you is this
whatever you're gonna do
make sure you've explained it thoroughly
to everyone
over dinner where everyone's sitting
together and everyone looks at each
other
and everyone's happy for each other and
everyone loves each other
we're not to fight about this after
we're gone or i'll come back and haunt
you people
this is the ramsey chef
life is full of firsts
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more
[Music]
firsts
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
charlie and rachel are with us hey guys
how are you
hey hey how's it going better than i
deserve welcome where do you guys live
we live in park city kansas just outside
of wichita
oh yeah very nice well welcome to
nashville thank you have you
all the way here to do a debt-free
scream how much have you paid off
we paid off forty thousand four hundred
and eighty five dollars
very good how long did that take 28
months good for you
and your range of income during that
time uh 65 to 80
000. cool what do you guys do for a
living i am a police officer
with the wichita police department and i
stay at home and have a
side gig where i refinish furniture oh
cool very good
so what kind of debt was this 40 000
uh it was two credit cards a car debt uh
also uh braces and then we also had to
cash flow emergency dental care that
happened uh when we were doing the uh
when we started the
the program okay wow yeah wow
so you guys were kind of normal yeah
yeah
yeah
just making money and it's all gone yeah
exactly yeah and uh
two and a half years ago 30 months or so
ago
something happened what happened uh you
know we really just got tired of
of our money just being gone like you
said like every month
uh we live paycheck to paycheck and at
the end of the month our money went to
everybody else
except for us yeah definitely we'd get i
think we did
davish for a long time so we decided so
you kind of knew
ramsay's stuff we did ramsey issue you
knew what you were doing a little bit
but
but didn't do it yeah and then we went
and did the class and
just decided that we just needed to go
full force and
get it done so the class gets you off of
center or you went to the class after
you got off the center
no that we were we were kind of doing
dave ish yeah and then our friend
offered the class
oh and they said hey yeah yeah so what's
the gas on the fire right it is
yeah yeah and it was you know right at
the beginning uh
the the class teacher encouraged us to
cut our credit cards up and i was very
hesitant that was kind of my
fallback that's when you knew you were
ish yes yes and then
uh probably a month after the class i
think i said you know what we're going
to cut these things up and we cut them
up and i've never had a credit card
again and i never will wow just like
that yeah
laid the pack of cigarettes down never
pick it up again that's exactly exactly
smoking again exactly and we've paid
cash for everything ever since and it's
been it's been wonderful
i love it i love it so this past year
has been
gnarly for stay-at-home
moms for police officers yes for
people's finances have you guys just
kept
taking another step and another step
what's kept y'all going through a
really messy year and a half or two
years
yeah it was uh you know we were right on
track uh we planned to pay it off in
probably like 20 months 24 months
and then one weekend i work extra
part-time jobs i work security at
churches oh yeah baseball games whatever
i can to make more money
and it all stopped it ended so you know
it was really just working together
and having that budget and sticking to
it that helped us get through it
and it extended it a little bit but you
know what we're not gonna quit
yeah it was a crazy year like you said
um just within 24 hours
all that extra money that we had worked
so hard for he worked so hard for
was gone because of covid and we're
thinking well
that's it we're just gonna be in debt
you know and then
um you know we had a rough year because
of all the
turmoil that our country's gone through
and the rioting and so
charlie actually worked so much over
time that we just took all that money
and just kept going just kept throwing
it at debt
and at the end it actually wasn't that
much longer it was only four months past
what we originally planned
so god still provided for us and it was
great but
um during that time you know there were
times where we thought man we're gonna
we're not gonna make our goal it's not
gonna happen but
it ended up being great and we got
through it yeah and i i mean i could say
uh when we first started just thinking a
thousand dollars a month
emergency fund seemed like unreachable
for me because it was like at the end of
the month you had like
25 dollars left over and uh
but it's possible yeah and in 40 000 if
you would ask me when we first started
that you're going to pay off 40
000 in 28 months i would have laughed
right but we put our minds to it and
worked together and we did it you know
and you had and you had all these hills
and valleys all along the way that you
didn't anticipate when you started
right once you put down the 40 and said
we're doing this but you didn't know
pandemic you didn't know you suddenly
you were going to lose all the ot
all the extra job stuff you didn't you
didn't know all these challenges were
going to come but what is so interesting
to me
is that a couple working together
as as one unit or a person
when they set something very clearly in
their mind
and then someone tells them or something
tells them oh you're not on track
we just automatically adjust our lives
to get back on track
right once we really believe it i mean
it's like we cannot
it's something upsetting to our
psychology that says oh
wait a minute that's already assumed
then i'm not going to unassume it we're
going to choose something else
right and you found another way right
exactly and god sent you another way i
mean
it's just it's so weird how you grab the
gravitational pull of a clearly defined
vision clearly divine goal
is uh it's pretty amazing i'm so proud
of y'all yeah
it's been it's been great and i think
you know in the last two years like
we we our car needed four brand new
tires all of a sudden
and it was i mean all of a sudden
well not all of a sudden but they don't
wear out all the stuff right right but
but uh
but we have the money and we just put
four new tires on there you realized it
all of a sudden
yeah crap these little belt things are
waving at you
when you go out i go out to the garage
that little thing's sticking out there
looking at me yeah we just started
paying attention more and it's amazing
what happens when you pay attention
and yeah a lot cheaper than a flat yes
exactly and yeah
and when we the first time we cash
flowed our christmas time
right was amazing because we really had
to strategically figure out you know
what all is going to be under the tree
and things of that nature for each other
and
and before we would just kind of throw
it on a credit card and then
see where we were at january one yeah
and our kids had to learn the word no
which
they lived through it so yeah right they
look like they're still breathing
shocking yeah they're quite alive yeah
that's just so exciting what do you guys
tell people the key to getting out of
that is
you know it's just working together and
really i don't think i'm more of the
free spirit
and i like to man i like to go to tgi
fridays and have the big steak and
potatoes
uh every friday and she's more of the
more the conservative one so it's really
working together and staying on that
budget and having that budget every
month is really what
what has kept us there and uh having
being both of us on the same page i
think
is the key i don't like to do the budget
even though i'm a saver it's just
it's stressful but it has to be done but
then once it's done it's like
okay now i have a road map now this is
where we are this is what we're doing
for the month so
it's kind of a crazy feeling but yeah i
don't know what we would do without the
budget now
yeah that's even scarier and you know
the security you
you feel having being out of debt and
just having a budget and you're having
money available for emergencies i can
tell you
husbands it's good for your spouses to
feel that security yeah and i could tell
the difference when
uh you know we're at this point we are
now yeah yeah it's a big deal yeah
financial peace yes exactly two words
that don't go together like fouchy math
pretty cool yeah pretty neat dude well
done you guys
thank you so proud of you very very well
done and you brought the kiddos
them up what are their names and ages
let's get them in the debt free this is
brooke and she's 14. she just turned 14.
and this is noah he's nine all right
good looking guys way to go
good family this is fun you change their
lives mom and dad
you're heroes thank you thank you i'm
proud of you yep well she's saving for a
call right now
yeah good stuff well we got a copy of
the legacy journey for you that's the
next chapter in your story you've
changed your legacy and you'll get to
read about that and learn more about it
as you go and also an extra copy of the
total money makeover so you can give
that away
like your friends encouraged you guys to
go to that financial peace university
class and when you went
ding ding yup no more ish right exactly
it's the antidote for ish there we go i
like it good stuff
all right charlie and rachel brook and
noah wichita kansas 40 thousand dollars
paid off in 28 months
making 65 to 80 count it down let's hear
a
debt-free scream three two
one one day
[Applause]
that is fabulous so well done you guys
incredible way to go well done
yeah that's how you pull it off
i love it two people with a goal can do
anything
it will adjust their lives to hit that
goal because you're going to hit bumps
and you just reset the steering reset
the steering i love it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today our question of the day
comes from one of america's finest
companies blinds.com
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
if you order a window blind
from them and you screw up the order you
screw up the order like you miss measure
you pick the wrong color i've done
stupid stuff
this company has a you did stupid stuff
policy and they'll fix your blinds
remake them
for free you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run all the time
save even more always use the promo code
ramseyblinds.com
all right today's question comes from
brian in texas
my girlfriend and i have been together
for six months i recently started
working with a real estate elp to buy my
first
house i know this is going to turn into
a huge fight
but i really don't want to bring my
girlfriend into the process
i am the one signing the documents and
i'm the one responsible for the loan
i'd prefer to have the home closed on
first and then tell her about it
rather than having to explain how she
does not get a vote in this process
please let me know how horrible of a
person i am and what the proper way to
handle this would be
what do you think dave ah danger danger
[Laughter]
there's something wrong with your
relationship dude that's right
there's something wrong that you don't
want to include her there's something
wrong he thinks it's going to be a fight
there's something wrong
yeah it just seems to be messy he knows
something about her
that he's uncomfortable with is that
fair uh
you know what i think huh i'm i'm
reading we're both reading between the
lines because this is all we've got
we've got this paragraph that's why
these are fun
that's why you can just make up whatever
we want brian come on he's a handsome
guy
yeah you can just paint him up how big
whatever he wants yeah
so she is already married
in her mind yup and he ain't nowhere
near close
[Music]
and she has a say in what he wears where
they go
what they eat what his car needs to be
cause they're already married in her
mind that's right and in his mind
we're just sort of dating so you don't
get to pick my house right
yeah i think that's what the breakdown
is and on the other side of that what
was the thing when
our kids were teenagers they called it
uh
d define the relationship dtr
define the relationship yes he has not
done this
no you know why because she's already
defined it for them i know
but they are not on the same wavelength
i'm guessing i have
i know nothing i've been married 39
years i've been out of the market so
long i don't know how this works okay
but
uh oh my gosh that's what it sounds like
it's a red flag to me if someone's been
together six months
and you want to i'm not worried about
hey this is your house she doesn't get a
vote that's all fine
it's that you are thinking about doing
something that's going to bring you this
much stress
this it's this big of an event in your
life and you want to hide
it from her and that tells me that you
guys are not settled in the way you all
communicate not settled in the way you
guys work together and so you feel like
you have to hide
go around her back because brian you're
being dishonest here
that's the reality now i don't think
you're making a bad decision by saying
you're a horrible person you're not
you're not a horrible person
you might be a drama queen not a
horrible person um so i think
man i'd sit down and say i'm about to
buy a house i've already picked one out
or i'm going to be picking one out this
is my decision this will be a hard
conversation right because if i'm
thinking if i'm dating someone for six
months
and you wouldn't exclude me from this
big of a thing that's a signal to me
right yeah that we're not anytime soon
gonna live in this house together nope
and not only that you don't even want me
to
like have input on the sidewalk right
like this is a big signal
yeah i think i just want to hug brian
i i you know on hug brian okay so one
one of two or three things
if i'm right and they're on different
wavelengths on
how close this is to marriage and what
the probability is that's going to end
up in marriage and is she going to live
there
she thinks she's moving in next week he
thinks maybe next decade
maybe maybe or maybe you're just my date
of the week
right um you're not you know so if if
they're
i think sir this might be a cue for you
to sit down and define the relationship
that's two of you too and say and you
know you would just say something like
i was thinking about doing a big
decision and i realized that
you were gonna maybe want more input in
that it made me realize we probably
weren't on the same track so
i'm not trying to run you off i like
where we are but i think you're over
here
might be over here and i might be over
here right and let's get aligned on that
and then if you can get aligned on we're
just dating
then it's not offensive for you to buy a
house
and it's never okay the second option is
this chick is
overbearing in a control freak and you
need to run
and run don't lie right yeah yeah just
go
you don't get a say because you're just
saying anything that's right we're not
together anymore right
because i don't i'm not if i if i'm
already scared of you and i'm not
married this is a problem that's the big
neon sign right yeah i hear this all the
time
so i go to play golf on saturday or
sunday morning and the
golf guy let me go out first because i
was by myself because sharon had the
grain babies
and i had to get like play real fast by
myself
before they woke up and she got to care
for them by ourselves because i
it's tag team event when you have three
grandbabies right so uh in other words i
got to get back to the house or i'm in
trouble and this golf game is not going
to have gone well for my day you follow
me yeah so
i'm standing there these three old guys
and they had me up with them i said guys
y'all let me go three minutes i'll be
out your way you'll never see me again
i'm gonna play so fast it's blinding
and they go oh yeah we understand we're
scared of our wives too
but it was like four old guys on the
golf tee
old men wife joke right right and
nobody's serious i'm not scared of my
wife of course
but he's scared of her that's right and
his fears reaction his fear is making
him become a person who lacks integrity
yeah so don't do that have the hard
conversation you're not a horrible
person
you you don't be a drama queen and don't
be cowardly
and dude she's gonna find out anyway
you're gonna buy a house
it's like oh yeah that thing up four
months ago i forgot to tell you i don't
think you're gonna have a hard
conversation now
or a hard conversation plus one about
how you lied to her
next month exactly either way have it
dude exactly that's the whole thing
brian you know what though
this is one of those things we're
talking about marriage and money in the
first segment
and how you got you and rachel doing
this money and marriage event this side
is tied together that's right because
now he's making a financial decision and
what is it doing it's reflecting
it he didn't have a question about how
to do the mortgage he didn't have a
question about whether he could afford
the house
he didn't have a money question in a
relationship question what was it
surfaced by
a money decision right and then his
response to dealing with that money
decision is making him
um it's revealing it's revealing there
you go
it's revealing in him a a default
setting to i'm gonna hide i'm gonna lie
i'm going to
put things in the drawer so she can't
see him right and so it's this
it's this the money reveals the
character and character reveals the
money it all works together
yeah yeah yeah yeah and he's not he's
not a person of lacking integrity no not
at all
all this is is it just signals problems
in a relationship absolutely there's
some kind of problem either she's an
over
bearing control freak or you guys have
are on different lanes or there's a
third possible option i don't know what
it is
but those are the two that come to my
mind now listen brian
next week when i'm in here with you dave
and we get a blinds.com question from
an angry girlfriend in texas yeah she
said you guys told my boyfriend to dump
me
that's not what we're saying just have a
hard conversation yeah well
no no i if she's a control freak i said
no
i didn't say that listen if the whole
thing comes down to she has to control
your decisions after six months
this ain't getting better done no this
is not going to get better this is no
thank you
or vice versa it doesn't matter with his
boyfriend or girlfriend that's right if
he's controlling all of her decisions
yeah right near him run girl it doesn't
fix after that's the wedding it's not
gonna it's not gonna get anything but
worse
that's right so there you go
uh yeah you know and like al
money things and relationship things do
share this in common too that you and
rachel doing that money and marriage
event together
if you extrapolate the decision and
expand it
the results of the decision in other
words you say
i'm going to reach 10 years out from
this decision how does it affect me
and i'm going to make it a hundred times
larger
so these relationship issues in this
email
in this blinds.com question 100 times
bigger
and 10 years from now and and
so the house had nothing to do with it
it was just the revealing point
that says okay i you know are you gonna
lie to your wife for ten years about
purchases
right are you gonna because you're
afraid of her reaction are you gonna
hide
or are you gonna be you know are you
gonna live with someone who's gonna try
to control all your decisions
and you can't come to a meeting of the
minds and discuss things and negotiate
through them
you know you know these are things you
reach out past just this decision and
sometimes the answer is go ding ding
ding
real clear they just open up for you wow
wow wow wow you got it brian you can do
it man
you got this i'm glad you do not me you
got this
this is the ramsay show
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
head to thermsyshow.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host ken coleman
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is
my co-host today open phones at
825-5225 ken is host of the ken coleman
show which airs on sirius xm as a
podcast and
over 75 radio stations across north
america answering your questions about
your career your job
finding work that matters work that has
meaning in plugging into it moving ahead
in the career that you've already got
all of those kinds of questions the
income side of the equation
i always deal with the outgo side just
about so we're here to answer both sides
of the
equation and help you out the phone
number triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two
five five two two five starting off this
hour
sammy in atlanta hi sammy welcome to the
ramsey show
hey thanks thanks dave thanks ken thanks
for taking my call sure what's up
hey um probably two years ago my wife
and i got serious about paying off our
80 000
debt um we're down to 29 000
um four years ago i left the public
teaching to go to private
so uh i left uh 30 000 in a trs fund and
kind of forgot about it
um so after four years it doesn't gain
um anything and i'm not contributing so
i have to move it over
so my wife and i want to know if we can
use that to
get six months ahead and pay the 9 000
penalty and take that money and go ahead
and be debt-free
well you can but i wouldn't borrow money
at 30 percent interest
to pay off your debt correct
so i wouldn't i mean
you know if if you call me up and said
hey i have a bank that'll loan me the
money it cost me nine grand
to borrow 30 so i can pay off this other
debt
and i'm gonna just pre-pay all the
interest nine grand you wouldn't even
ask me that question
right and it's the same thing dude
you're about to give the government a
third of your money for no apparent
reason other than you just want to be
out of debt really bad which i really
want you out of that bad too
but i don't want you out of debt 33
percent bad
right it's just looking at being able to
uh
be six months ahead of the next step
which would be
more than the nine we would be losing
but it's still losing now
if i suggested to you that you borrow
money from a bank at 30
interest to pay off your debt and and
you said i don't want to do that and i
said the answer was
oh you're looking at six months you're
going to be out six months sooner
you would say ramsay you've lost your
dadgum mind
right but that was your comeback
yeah no i already knew the answer before
i actually called but
i just decided to be this far along in
the journey hey man i'm with you i want
you out
so uh you're gonna be out you're gonna
be out it's just gonna be six months
slower
and i'll give you a prediction it's
gonna be four months slower because
you're over this you're ready to be
done now take your old retirement and
roll it to an ira with a smart investor
pro don't pay any taxes on it
and let it grow from this point without
taxes and you're going to love that you
did that later that's a better move long
term don't give the government a third
of your money
it just doesn't make sense and you can
ask the question six different ways and
i'm still going to give you the same
answer
every time that's the strange thing
about me ken yeah you kind of know what
you believe why you believe it's fairly
consistent
very consistent it's ridiculously boring
by the way that's a general rule of
thumb that's the correct answer and a
very specific answer to his question but
it's always a good rule of thumb to try
to avoid giving the government any of
your money
it's always a good place to start let's
just start and assume they suck at
handling money right
so any money any money you give to them
falls under the heading of bad
stewardship
god is not pleased no with me when i
send them money because they mishandle
it yeah
so and i'm not going to send it to
anybody else that mishandles it
either if i can help it so uh because
it's my
job is to handle it well yeah so yeah
yes
they're they suck at anything having to
do with money
just it's that simple there's nothing
you know how many times do you hear the
word government and efficiency in the
same sentence unless there's an n
in front of it like in efficiency yeah
you just don't hear them in the same
sentence it doesn't come up so now don't
send the money
keep the money for yourself yes it's
always better
it's always better you're not being
patriotic it's just bad it's just ugly
don't don't send them money they're not
good with it yeah
clay's in austin texas hey clay how are
you good how are you dave
better than i deserve what's up um
my wife and i are thinking about
downsizing into an rv
selling our house and down closing into
an rv we
did this before we had kids and now we
have kiddos
and we're kind of wondering if it's a
good idea i mean
i know the market's hot right now to
sell our house so we'll make some money
on it and
probably get out of bed i haven't put
complete pen to paper
because i don't know what we're actually
going to make on it how many kids and
how old
i've got two kids they're four and six
okay and your motivation for doing this
is
getting out of death no don't do it
no no two reasons
four and six in an rv
reason number three yeah rv's
rvs go down i was too reasons rv goes
down
in value no no we already have the rv
oh it still goes down in value yeah
now you don't own any appreciating
assets you only own depreciating assets
okay is the rv paid for
yes what do you owe on it i don't know
i'm sorry what's it worth
what's it worth what's it worth what's
it worth uh about about 15 000.
okay cool all right and what's your
household income
about 55 depending on overtime
good for you okay well much like our
last caller i love the motivation to be
debt debt-free i'm with you
on that i'm not willing to pay the price
that you're willing to pay
i love my grandbabies the idea of being
stuck with two of them in an
rv for the rest of my life until they
grow up
is suicidal for me i just couldn't do it
one of us one of us would die
yeah what's your time to do it for the
rest of our life i was
i was talking about what we i forgot to
say we're trying to move to a different
city
and do it that way okay
for how long how long are you gonna be
in the rv uh
we're expecting two years max maybe
three yeah i i
you can do whatever you want to do
you're a grown up you called and asked
me what i would do
i personally could not do that would not
do that uh i don't
think the financials are that great on
what you're talking about i don't think
it's like a big windfall
and the lifestyle of it i just couldn't
do i mean i've got friends at rv
i got friends that have i can think of
one right now that's got three kids and
they are
it's an adventure they live everywhere
and they do it on purpose but they're
not doing it so they can get out of debt
they're doing it because they
love being on the road you know that
kind of stuff but i
would the ramses have done that when we
were on our get out of debt journey
uh the answer is there wouldn't be any
ramses if we had done that
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phone's a triple eight eight two
five five
two two five according the united states
census bureau nearly one in ten people
relocated last year
and that was in 2020 that means this
year there's a good chance you or
someone you know is going to move
it feels like a thousand unknowns out
there when you're moving
but you can't lose focus on one of the
most important personal and financial
factors
in your move and that's housing i
recommend getting a
quality real estate agent like one of
our endorsed local providers our elps
in your corner to help you navigate this
cray-cray market we're in
this market is nutty and
uh uh you know most of the stuff i'm
reading says it may have peaked
in may uh and it's maybe june is going
to be
hot but it's slowing down it's still
going to be a hot market
depending on where you live and what the
situation is but
it's a good time to sell and a crazy
time to buy
and i'm not saying you can't buy but
it's nutty out there and you really it's
not amateur hour baby you don't need
somebody sold three houses last year to
help you with this deal
this is too freaking complicated to
navigate this so
go to rent get a ramsey trusted agent
what you do is go to ramseysolutions.com
agent and you can get the people we
trust here at ramsey to help you with
that
a ramsey trusted agent ramsey
solutions.com
agent mark is in springfield illinois
hey mark
welcome to the ramsey show hey
i can't thanks for taking my call sure
what's up so i've
got a good situation to be in where uh
family income is around 600 000
and trying to figure out for baby step
four
our retirement accounts don't equal up
to 15 percent
last year what i had done was put some
of it in an
index fund to make up the rest of it but
i was trying to figure out if it would
be more appropriate to just put the rest
of it straight onto the house
instead of putting it into an index to
try to equal 15
what a wonderful problem to have
yeah what do you do for a living dude
i'm a er doc and wife's still in
residency
oh okay all right so both of you are in
the aren't going to be mds
okay yeah so it's not going to get
anything but better hopefully
um yeah it took a bit of a hit last year
with the coven stuff but
it's still in just fine yeah yeah but
nothing
nothing yeah wow okay um
how much do you owe on your home it's
down to around 100 we just kind of
got a little starter home to begin with
okay
well what i would do is you know you can
you can play with this back and forth if
you want
the point being that you should be at
baby step 7 instantaneously
and then you should save and pay cash
for your next home which keeps you at
baby step seven would you agree with
that
yes yeah that was actually what we were
thinking for the index fund was that was
going to be
yeah how much is in the index for it's
about 20
uh 29 now 24 of that was the principle
that we put in last year
yeah i mean i don't mind cleaning all of
that out and other cash you can lay your
hands on just knocking the hundred out
and then what you need to do is you need
to budget and say i'm going to save
i'm going to invest systematically x
percent
and the rest i'm going to pile up to pay
cash for the move up house
once i've paid cash for that house and
there's nothing left to do but invest
and be generous and enjoy some of it but
you're there's no way you're gonna be
able to consume
what's gonna end up being close to a
million dollar income
correct yeah now that is uh right what
we're looking at for it and
yeah yeah we'll see if she's doing full
time or not when she gets out because
we're in a
very good spot but yeah you're going to
be able to do whatever you want to do
but my point is you know you at baby
step 7 you just
invest you know and so you can invest
more than 15 less than 15 percent or
whatever and so um you know you don't
you're not like i've got a friend that
makes uh a million six a year
okay and we were looking at his stuff
the other day he was asking me similar
questions
and i said well number one you're a baby
step seven so the 15 doesn't apply
anymore it's
invest and so then you just start saying
okay what are my investment goals
because your consumption goals
unless you're just a weird you know like
you're some kind of rock star
or something uh you know you're just
spending out your ears like
dysfunctionally
you're not gonna consume much of one
million six you know
or one million you're going to consume
some of it but you're gonna enjoy it but
then you're gonna be
highly generous and highly investing and
that's the only three things you can do
with it is consumption enjoy it
and invest and be generous so it doesn't
matter if it's eight percent
because that's still eighty thousand
dollars a year
you know so you just lay out some
percentages and say how how much
how quickly do we want to have a 10
million dollar net worth
and having a million dollar income you
ought to have 10 million net worth
yeah this is a the 600 in a new
development for since i just got out of
residency a couple years ago so yeah
but what i'm doing what i'm saying is i
laid the baby steps out to extrapolate
25 years into the future for you and all
i'm telling you to do is whatever
percentages you put on consumption
investment and generosity just make sure
they extrapolate with a million dollar
income
out 10 years from now and you got 10
million net worth
sounds good and i don't care if that's
2.6 investment
or 12.6 investment but do it on purpose
that's the trick the intentionality is
the thing ken yeah and that's why like
you said when we get to baby step seven
now that that whole phrase living like
no one else i mean you're investing
so much i mean you just got tremendous
impact at that point
with whatever you do with your money
that is within reason and very smart
very wise and congratulations to them i
mean this is wonderful
well you know what else i like i want to
call out he pointed out you know
he didn't do the normal doctor thing
they got a starter house
they got a smaller house and as a result
his wife is finishing residency
and they only owe a hundred thousand on
this first house they're gonna knock
that out with their income be able to
pay cash
for you know your probably normal doctor
house and so credit to them have been
shocked to hear his house was a million
five no you wouldn't have
it's very normal and so forth dollar
income yeah fantastic income
but uh boy i love the discipline there
and uh what a path there on that's
fantastic
yeah that that's um that's the time that
omd thing paid off right there
that's right that's right very good
peter is with us peter is in raleigh
north carolina and hey peter how are you
hey i'm doing well how are you today
better than i deserve what's up
awesome um my question is very similar
to the previous caller
um not the 600 000 guy but the other guy
about the rv
but my wife and i um we've been on the
baby steps for about a year we've been
married two years
and uh we're looking to save extra money
moving into an rv on their family farm
we're paying 1100 in rent right now we
make about growth
75 thousand a year and we have a baby
come december
with 18 000 in student loans
and we're just trying to figure out
that's a good idea or not
so the parents own the rv and it's on
their farm am i understanding that
correctly
yeah they got about 100 acres and they
kind of offered us to move in there
because we really
want to get the um debt paid before the
baby comes and
so how long as well what's the plan with
the new baby to live in the rv
on the farm how long maybe two years
i just i again as dave said the previous
caller
you could do whatever you want it's not
like this is a bad decision certainly
has good financial opportunities because
i'm assuming you're living rent-free is
that
a correct assumption uh yeah we would
just pay for utilities whatever it costs
to uh
rvs in north carolina it is yes sir
yeah i mean two years long time to live
with a baby in an rv
even a little one just one i just think
that's that's uh
i probably wouldn't do it but you know
how fast what's the difference it's
gonna make
what if you've played this one year one
year difference that's what i said
one year yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
well i think to our thinking is she'll
be closer to her family when the baby
comes because i'm working about 60 hours
a week right now with ups
and so she will be closer to her family
and that's kind of a concern too because
we're about 30 minutes away from them
um and i'm kind of gone a lot during the
night you come
out here till 9 10 o'clock you can do
what you want to do
dave and sharon ramsey would not have
done that uh
again we're not i don't think it's
bad i don't think you're making a bad
decision it's a lifestyle decision
uh an rv in north carolina in december
is cold it's hard to keep it warm
and i'm not living in there with a baby
[Music]
so
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
jason and heather are with us hey guys
welcome
hey dave hey ken good to have you guys
where do you guys live
we live in greenfield center new york
right near saratoga springs
wow bit of a hall to nashville yeah a
little bit
yeah well welcome it's good to have you
guys and all the way down south to do a
debt free screen
yep that's right how much of you guys
paid off 185 thousand dollars dude
how long did that take it took us uh 30
months good for you
and your range of income during that
time uh 185 to 235 thousand dollars
cool what do you guys do for a living i
am a regional
sales manager for a building materials
manufacturer
i'm a health coach and a personal
trainer ah very cool
so building materials might have been
interesting to sell this year
it's been an interesting ride it's been
crazy
bars of gold are cheaper than two
befores yep
and final sighting and pvc trim for me
yeah well same thing yeah
oil-based oh my gosh it's just crazy i'm
sure i'm sure the prices went nuts crazy
yeah they still are wow so what kind of
debt was 185
000 uh we had a couch we had three cars
we had five credit cards we had
uh some personal loans some fitness
equipment and
uh somebody's college loans somebody
somebody sitting off camera yeah okay to
be named later
all right yeah we'll get we'll get into
this a little bit so you guys were
normal very
making a lot of money and spending even
more
absolutely what was the wake up call so
i uh dates back to the beginning of the
marriage when i took over the finances
and uh i was always mainly the the bread
winner she stayed home with the girls
for
a long period of time and i felt
financially responsible
uh for everything but we had credit
cards and when we ran out of money
groceries would go on the credit cards
and then uh
i don't know probably about five or six
years ago somebody had given me the
total money makeover and i read it so i
knew
conceptually uh about the snowball and
uh
and then i was doing the finances one
day
at the beginning of the 30 month period
and
i made the spreadsheet i did it all and
then
eight months went by and i paid off
about two thousand dollars
so at the sa at that same time i was
training for a marathon
i wanted to listen to maybe like a
business or finance
uh podcast i found you and i was i think
i was running eight or nine miles that
day
and uh so i got to listen to a lot of
debt-free screams and
a lot of callers but then i literally
got in the truck and i ran home and uh i
told heather that the the sky was
falling
and that we were in trouble yeah oh wow
he came home he was in
panic mode yeah so i wasn't from having
run eight miles
no and you know i i didn't even realize
how bad things were
i wasn't really paying attention to be
honest so so it was just like the
information just smacked you
yeah it hit me like a ton of bricks and
i felt
overwhelmed i felt like a failure to
myself
to my wife to my kids
i remember that feeling i remember it
and it's a it's a
and the weird thing is is the numbers
didn't change just your attitude about
them did
yeah during the eight mile run nothing
was different no it's true
it's just the way you looked at it and
you just went oh this sucks
i didn't realize how bad this sucks
because you're a sales guy what you were
doing was probably what i've always done
before i had that moment and that was
i've always tried to out earn my
stupidity
i i thought i could just make a little
more that's all i did and and
i've always done side jobs construction
yeah and uh
that kind of kicked in during the the
pandemic because nobody was traveling
and everybody wanted a new deck so
i uh i've got all the tools and i went
out and
did that and at the same time as you
said building materials were going crazy
the only thing is i had to you know do
everything via zoom from home
so it was a little bit of an adjustment
wow
so uh you come home from that epiphany
run
yeah and uh heather what did you say
well i was in denial you know and part
of me was just thinking like well
everybody has
debt you know we're not that it's not
that bad you know
so i was scared but i was also just kind
of pretending it wasn't
all that bad we'll get out of this yeah
so did you sell anything or you just
cash flow every bit of this
we cashflowed a lot of it um she
actually closed down her fitness studio
and we sold off some fitness equipment
that we had loans on
that brought in about 14 grand
but she closed the town in february
right before the pandemic so the time it
could not have been better
yeah except that that fitness equipment
was very valuable during the pandemic
yeah we wish we had to hold the hell
down to a little bit longer we sold
we sold two good time to close the
business bad time to sell the equipment
yeah absolutely still not a bad time but
just later on people going crazy because
you can't get it
right right right wow you guys what a
cool
what a cool journey yeah yeah i love
asking this question so
in this moment where he comes home we
have the discussion there's a lot of
fear there
you can still hear the emotion on you as
you just recounted it
yeah um and and i'm just curious was
there a moment where this thing went
from
fear to oh we're making some progress
what was that moment
yeah that's actually when i came on
board because at first i was like
okay this sounds like a really good idea
but we're never going to be able to do
this i didn't believe it until i started
seeing the progress and i started seeing
you know the first one get paid off and
the second one i'm like oh
this this might work and then i got and
then i got excited
yeah taking full commission checks and
throwing it at it was
you know it got easier actually
as you saw the progress you know the
pandemic actually helped us because we
didn't do it you know we were just home
and so his commission checks you know
all of our money our girls play
basketball aau basketball it's very
expensive we took all that money
and and put out the debt yeah just like
that boom i love it
well you know personal finance is 80
behavior it's 20
head knowledge you're both fitness geeks
obviously from uh you know eight mile
runs fitness studio
uh and uh so these did you see a
parallel between the
discipline the natural discipline that
you teach and you both
have not natural but the decided
discipline in the
physical realm or physical fitness realm
did you see the parallel back to the
money piece
absolutely yeah we talk about it all the
time our our meetings would i could
never get her to sit down and look at a
spreadsheet
uh she would she would just glaze over
and start staring off into space but so
we started running every friday morning
together
yeah we have pictures of ourselves
totally frozen running in uh you know
19 below weather but that's where we had
our dream conversations and our finance
conversations and that's where she was
in her element so
yeah but that's that's where we're
talking about it and that's what made it
you know real that's what made it work
well and
you know you're also uh you got a little
adrenaline going then so it's not bad
absolutely
absolutely get those endorsements you
kind of you know you're kind of hopeful
as opposed to depressed that's right
that's right
very cool good for you guys what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is
well a couple things i mean i think just
like losing weight like what i teach
people
you know you have to have a deep why you
know why are we doing this
you know what we just want to save some
money i mean it has to be much deeper
than that
and uh our life has improved what was
your
so much my why what was your else why
our why was just for a better life to
not have that that debt over our head
and that stress
the stress that was putting on our
marriage um
we are so much happier as a family now
yeah for me
i mean it was obviously the y with the
you know our kids
changing our legacy our family tree is
uh important
and uh i was always telling them when
they got their job that they were gonna
you know they should save half of what
they make and put it in the bank and i
wasn't living by those principles
so i kind of that's part of me feeling
like a fraud so um
you know the fact that we were able to
to reach over and
at the end and pay off almost 40 000 of
college loans between parent plus and
her loans and we're cash flowing
everything now is
pretty special so yeah there's a big one
yeah i like that we're celebrating on
this trip
yeah well i'm so proud of you guys thank
you
thank you so much you're an incredible
couple very cool
very cool brought the kiddos with you
what are their names and ages
so we have caroline and she is almost 20
and lauren's birthday is in about a week
she'll be 16.
okay we got a copy of the legacy journey
for you and the total money makeover for
you to give away and help somebody count
it down
let's hear a debt-free scream you guys
ready
three two one we're
[Music]
there debt-free is baby this is how it's
done
[Applause]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host
joe is with us in albuquerque new mexico
hi joe welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave and ken how you doing great how
can we help
good um i'm just calling because i'm in
a little bit of a predicament and i just
want to see
what your guys's suggestion was um so i
have a full-time
job and i also do financial coaching
on the side and i've gotten to the point
to where my coaching is actually making
more money than my
full-time job which is great um and i
have a baby on the way with my family
and i'm just like in this point where
i'm dependent on both income
in order to provide and you know um
make my uh my goals happen and
everything like that
and the my full-time job i like it but
i'm just not
passionate about it but i'm afraid of
making that leap
to where with me being dependent on both
incomes
you know i might not be able to make
that happen might not
might not be able to make it provide so
now what were you doing before you had
the second income how are you making it
well before the second income um i was
renting
and i i had a really good low rent um
now we own a
we own a home and um i was also single
at the time
too so you know now i have uh one
stepdaughter and and one on the way and
um it was feasible at that point yeah
what's your what's your day job and how
much do you make
make about 40 a year with the day job
and about 40 a year on the other
about 50. about 50 on the other okay
yeah
so so if you're dependent on this
then you got to stay i mean the reason
you're afraid is because sometimes fear
is telling us hey back away from the
ledge because if i fall over the ledge
it's
it's going to be really bad and so if
you're truly dependent on this i mean
90k
is really good and if your financial
coaching has grown to this point from 0
to 50k
then it stands to reason as committed as
you are and the fact that you've now
proven this
it's going to continue to grow so i
would stay in the day job
until we aren't dependent on it anymore
i mean that
at its simplest that's what the answer's
got to be
and i'm glad you've called on this
because i know you don't have any
passion for the day job but that's why i
call it the day job
and you know people need to understand
that
there is no dream job without several
day jobs i don't hear of many stories
other than your random reality show
stories like that where you just
immediately step into the dream job so
i'd stay in it and get through this baby
keep
rocking it and then keep socking money
away uh let's let's just play this thing
out
and when you start to feel like oh i
don't have any passion for the day job i
want to do this coaching thing
well what you need to do is have a real
dose of gratitude boy i'm grateful for
this day job
because it is the platform by which i
have been able to stand on
and i will eventually step off of into
the dream job
so i don't think it's that much further
away if if you are conservative what do
you think
uh the projection looks like to step
into this financial coaching full time
yeah because you're going to increase
your financial coaching income and
you're going to decrease your lifestyle
until the two meet that's right
yeah i would say so once the baby comes
um
you know before we were before we knew
that we were pregnant we were bringing
in an extra probably
you know 1500 to 2500
a month extra depending on the month um
so that i was in a really good position
and i was thinking about making that
leap
but now the baby's here i'm like well i
have to stay for the baby so now i'm
kind of thinking like okay
maybe once the baby does come then i can
make that
that jump um and in the meantime you
know i got six months
i can keep building that and here's the
thing um if you're having to make a
jump yeah it's you don't do it that's it
you can make a step
that's because you don't need to make a
jump yeah okay this is listen get in
your budget
you're pretty disciplined with your
budget yes or no
yes all right so the budget's going to
tell you when it's time this is not a
i don't know lick my finger stick it in
the wind and see which way i go no
it this is a budget answer the budget
will tell you when you can move from the
day job to the dream job do not
overthink this
and and listen when you start to feel
impatient
get back to clarity on why i do the day
job what the day job has provided for me
how much longer i've got to go
and then you can stay with it yeah you
can say you know
there's only three miles left in this
13.1
half marathon and you can you can gut
your way through
the last three miles uh but
you you if you just go i've got to run
for the rest of my life
then you're going to stop so you need to
you need to see the end of it by
increasing your income
on the on the financial coaching and
decreasing
your lifestyle so that the two can cross
and you can quit and
maybe and i really think this is the
case the baby is going to be a lot less
expensive than somehow you've got it in
your head
that a kid is sandy's in kansas city hi
sandy how are you
hi how are you dave better than i
deserve how can we help
um my husband and i have a little bit of
a discrepancy
we're both in our 70s and i'm retired
he is semi-retired he works part-time
um i have always we have always paid
um ever since we've been married and
we've always paid an extra hundred
dollars
on our mortgage and a month just on the
principal
um and um i found that it you know
brings in mortgage saying really really
rapidly
and my husband since because of our age
and we lost
a lot of money in the markets our
financial advisor we didn't get out in
time
and um whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
whoa just stop right you lost a lot of
money because you didn't get out in time
i didn't get out at all and i haven't
lost a dime
well we didn't get out in what was it 80
was it 85
1985 no no what was it when the market
0.05 when the markets went bottom
uh yeah i was six and five yeah
yeah we had a lot we haven't had all
that many investors with a financial
planner
and you didn't leave it uh
no we left it it stayed there but we
just never came back
well yes it has well ours
ours didn't honey the market is ninefold
fold what it was in 19
in 2006. it is now we're not in it now
we got out probably five years five or
six years after
that crash because we lost half of
everything we had
and it scared us and he seemed to want
to keep putting us in more risky stuff
and we got
maybe it was our fault maybe we you know
we we kind of panicked a little bit
um but uh we took that money then and
we've got it in
an annuity okay so how much is that how
much is that nest egg today
we've got 400 000 likes and how much do
you owe on your mortgage
uh we owe 97 about 96 000. okay
i would and you're 70 you're 70 years
old
i'm 74 and my husband's 76. okay and do
you have income
in addition to the nest egg you have
like pension and social security
we're getting social security and we're
getting we're taking money out of my
life insurance policy group
um this was what it was set up for we
set it up to be able to draw money off
of it
plus we also have an annuity that we're
getting so you have a whole life life
insurance policy
yes okay um
well you've got so many things going on
here that i don't know if i can address
them all but i'll give it a shot
okay number one i would have you sit
down with a financial advisor like a
smart vester pro
click smart vester pro at ramsey and
ramseysolutions.com and see if you can
get some help because you're not going
to get a radio answer in one minute
that's going to do everything
i would get rid of the whole life policy
i would take the cash value out i would
invest that
i would look at these investments and
see how they're invested because
you've apparently panicked and have not
gotten
good advice or haven't followed it and
you've uh
you've taken it on the chin on your
investing if you have 400
000 and if you can live off of the
social security income
and depending on what the cash value is
in this rip-off whole life policy that
you
love right now but when you understand
the numbers on it you're going to hate
it
i'm going to pay off your house today
out of some of this money i'm gonna
scrape together some of this money and
i'm gonna pay off your house today
and when you're debt-free and you have
300 or 400 depending on what this cash
value is
and depending on what these annuities
are and other things and you put that in
a pile
you can live off of that income with no
house payment
at all and so i disagree with both you
and your husband
i'd be out of debt as soon as you get
all this organized and understand it
as quickly as i could get it all cashed
in and moved around i would
be out of debt immediately house and
everything and then that sets you in a
whole different place of peace of mind
for your retirement and i think you'll
be just fine you will not be fine if you
don't quit
jumping in and out of the market
depending on what day you planning
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
theramsieshow.com
thanks for listening
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host ken coleman ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author of the book the proximity
principle
host of the ken coleman show where he
talks about careers and
jobs and getting work you love and work
that matters
he is my co-host today as we take your
calls the phone number triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five
michael's with us in wisconsin hi
michael how are you
good dave hey ken uh just got a quick
question for you here
i uh recently about a year ago left my
job and they had a punch in there
through the sponsor attack system
it's a 401 a plan there's about 60 000
in it i know you always recommend to
roll that over when you leave or take it
to a
you know personal investment i'm
wondering if i should
do that and leaving that plan you lose
the employer contributions
which is about 50 so that'd be 30 000
i'm wondering what my best move is if i
let it sit and
access it when i'm able to and i'd be
eligible to which is age 50
or i'm 30 years old right now or do i
take that out and take a portion and a
loss and
invest it the the 401k
plan at your old company does not vest
your matching
until you're 50. it's a 401 e
i know but that just means after tax is
all that means
uh yeah they don't invest your matching
uh true yes correct
that's asinine okay
um and it's how much money
sixty thousand that's the match portion
uh thirty thousand nine three thousand
is their match
okay and how what's it invested in
uh it's distributed oh geez
i don't even know what the breakdown is
they are pretty limited on what they
give you
you don't get to choose your um
investments in that plan yeah how old
are you
30. you don't get to choose the
investments in your plan
uh negative it's a pension plan to stay
okay here's what's running through my
head and then you can decide what you
want to do
um you're how old now again
30 30. 30 years old okay so for 20 years
you either are going to have 30 000
60 000 underperforming
sucking
sixty thousand or you're going to have
thirty thousand performing
well yeah in good mutual funds i figured
that was about you were going to go
and i don't know which one's going to
end up with more money
is the wait a minute wait yes i do the
30
000 will double if you've got it
invested at 10 percent
if you're if your mutual funds perform
at 10 which they should
i will double about every seven years
and so it would double three times in 20
years 21 years
so it would go from 30 to 60 to um
okay i can do this wait a minute it'll
go from um
30 to 60 to 120
to 240. okay that'll be your 30 000
it'll double three times one
two three times that's it okay now 60
let's say it's making i don't know
you having i guess what the stupid thing
is making
i would guess i i've looked at the
averages over the
course of the last say 40 years
put it all together i think i came out
with like a seven or eight percent
average so
okay it's seven percent it'll double
every ten years
okay so 60 would be 120
would be 240. it's exactly the same yeah
okay your 30 will grow to as much as
that 60 will grow
if you invest it at 10 or greater versus
7 percent
in a 20-year period of time i actually
could do it math that's crazy i did it
but
okay but the yeah that so uh and here
here's the other thing
um there is a
there's a philosophical spiritual thing
that happens when you take control of
your money
and someone else is not in control of it
in other words you've kind of got it
tucked over here in this underperforming
crappy thing or you take it out and you
say
i'm responsible
my destiny is in my hands
and there's something that happens in in
that inside of you
assuming you take control and you take
you know you take your destiny in your
own hands
then you will end up with more and so i
always when there's a tie
i always take my money and figure i'm my
best
shot not the freaking state government
i'm my best shot
and in case of a tie now if this had
been double
leaving it with the state i would have
held my nose and left it there
but it's coming to come out about the
same plus or minus the
i'm in control of my own destiny factor
and ken we see that
when in lots of areas of people's lives
that when you take personal
responsibility when you take control
when you say this is up to if it's to be
it's up to me
thing and you you shoulder the wheel you
put your shoulder to the wheel
we see a change in their careers we see
a change in their marriages we see it
changing their money
yeah engagement is what the real what's
going on there is now i'm engaged if
it's just sitting there and the
government's handling money well it's
everything's passive if i'm handling it
it's not passive anymore it's active
and that is an engagement issue and i
absolutely couldn't agree more you know
when someone takes responsibility for
their health
their marriage their parenting and you
become very engaged
well all of a sudden you feel the pain
you feel the victories
everything has got so much more
personal of involvement in it and
there's no question that's going to win
for him because now he's looking at that
he's got his dashboard you know set up
with a investor pro and he's watching
that thing grow
he's also adding to that thirty thousand
dollars as well
so yeah i think that's the right move
well you're gonna be doing that you know
you know in your other accounts and your
other retirements but that 30
yeah he can versus that 60. yeah they
both
should end up and i don't trust the
government dave i'll be honest i don't
know what i don't know it like you know
it but i don't know could the state
screw that up oh yeah they could screw
it up
okay so that to me is another look at
the finances of a state
exactly how badly like i mean if you're
in illinois
you're very afraid you know so yeah
that's even more reason to take the 30
out
math eludes them you know so yeah it's
uh i mean you got states like the state
of tennessee is very well run
right you know in terms of the business
aspects of the state
uh so uh you know you don't have to sit
and tremble about it but i mean there's
some of these states pension funds are
in trouble
oh because the state is just they just
suck yeah at running these things so
yeah that's another factor in there i
mean i wasn't thinking about the failure
side of it i was more thinking about the
upside
yeah but yeah this idea that's a good
word engagement
if something happens people that engage
an
area of their life are 100 of the time
more successful in that area
than people who wait on someone else to
fix that area of their life
that's what it comes down to a hundred
percent of the time now get with a smart
investor pro and roll that puppy over
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 a month
by switching
to pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey
to save 50 off your first month pure
talk
simply smarter wireless
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
if you're in debt we know you can feel
like you're fighting a losing battle it
gets scary
if you feel like you're stuck you can't
get ahead no matter what you do
you're scared i know how that feels i've
been there
it doesn't have to be this way
when you attack debt like your life
depends on it with a system that's
proven you can take back your paycheck
you can get control of your life we'll
help you get there
we've done it with almost 10 million
people in financial peace university
in this class you learn our proven plan
that's helped millions of people pay off
their debt
really fast and you never
you'll never make the changes that you
need to do unless you stick to a budget
and that's why you also get the premium
version of our budgeting tool every
dollar
and all of this is available with a
ramsey plus membership
so you want to go to financial peace
university you want the every dollar
budgeting tool
you want some online coaching you want
some of the other classes that we've got
you want access to some of the live
events like the money and marriage event
coming up july 16th
all of that is part of the ramsey plus
membership
so you can get ahead it's possible
you can do this start your free trial of
ramsey plus
text trial to 33 789
text trial two three three seven
eight nine patrick is with us in new
york hi patrick welcome to the ramsey
show
mr ramsey mr coleman it's a pleasure
thank you for taking my call
our pleasure sir how can we help ah so
i have been blessed recently i lost my
father years ago
i just lost my grandmother but i am
blessed in the fact that
i am going to be inheriting what my
father would have inherited
um so i am going to be gifted half a
million dollars from my grandmother
her estate i started following your
program in october
i've paid off two cars since i've read
the total money makeover
and i've also contacted a smart investor
pro
my issue lies within i mean i can run
through the baby steps
in one shot but then what do i do after
that
wow how old are you it's a lot to take
in
how old are you i'm 37. okay
and what's your household income uh
between my wife and i is 150.
excellent excellent and so after you pay
off all your debt your home you have an
emergency fund in place
and put money aside for kids college if
that applies how much money of the half
million will you have left
probably about half because i have 160
on the mortgage 90 on the student loans
okay all right and you have children
i do i always make the joke i have two
mortgages and only one house because uh
two children in daycare
okay so we'd set aside some of the
remaining 250 for kids college with a
smartvestor pro
and then the rest of it we're going to
begin to invest and to enjoy
uh once you reach baby step 7 baby step
seven is
everything's paid off now we're gonna
obviously fully fund all retirement
that's available to you
keep the government's hands off of any
money you can 401ks roth iras
anything you can do and keep your keep
you know fully fund everything
but that really comes out of your budget
which will be easy to do because you
don't have a single bill in the world
now
okay and college you set college aside
with a smart investor pro out of this
and so uh you know we'll we'll
you know you're probably gonna have i
don't know 150 000 or more
a little bit more left and then what you
need to do is say there's three things
you can do with money in baby step seven
you can
give it with generosity and you should
you can enjoy it and spend some of it on
you guys
lifestyle and you should and you can
invest it
some of it and you should uh and so
if you you know say we're going to spend
x on
something for enjoyment we're going to
uh
do this piece of generosity and get the
you know get the levers
starting to pull where we have the
rhythm of generosity ongoing in our life
from this point forward
um and uh then then you invest a chunk
and you're probably just looking for
some good mutual funds to invest in at
this stage of the game because you're
not gonna
really have a big pile of money left by
the time we do all of those different
things
correct now is that just kind of like a
line budget
item because i probably could save about
half of our income monthly
that would be like you said do all three
things with that
yeah um well i mean you've got this
chunk of money that you can do that with
and
you've got this tremendous room in your
budget because you don't even have a
house payment now
in our discussion right and so you can
do a little bit of
all of it uh and the trick is just to
keep some kind of intentionality
because listen here's the thing people
don't blow their entire paycheck
uh intentionally they do it because they
don't have a plan
uh people don't give so much that they
destroy their lives and their financial
plan with outrageous crazy
out-of-control generosity
that almost never happens by the way but
um that
you know but they don't do that on ac
they would do that on accident without
having a plan
so you plan some giving you plan some
enjoyment
and you can just make it a percentage of
your uh of your income from this point
forward and you can apply that
percentage to
this last chunk of money that's left
after these other goals are hit
yeah i was going to recommend dave that
that patrick and his wife sit down and
say hey
who is somebody we'd love to bless that
could be an organization
that could be their church uh that a
non-profit could be a family in the area
whatever
but really when that 250 if that's what
they've got left over and they figure
out okay we're going to invest we're
going to enjoy
and then we're going to give and i think
really planning that giving
and saying all right in our budget do we
want to tie that they don't have to
but if there's a cause that they really
believe deeply in i love the idea of
giving some of that chunk
to get them started and then work it
into their monthly budget like he was
asking
because i i find that we hear from folks
that live like no one else and then you
get to that point where they've got so
much room
and there's some sort of guilt as
opposed to if you could focus on giving
a decent percentage of that
boy you're really going to have the
juice that comes with all of that labor
and all of that you know in this case
you're aided by a big
uh inheritance but it doesn't matter uh
then you don't feel guilt over you
shouldn't need
anyway but but by giving some of it boy
there's a wonderful emotion
attached to the discipline and that
consistent giving
in the budget itself i know stacey and i
have always felt that way as we've given
to our church
but whether you go to church or not
intentional giving when you get to this
point at baby step 7
i think you'll enjoy the money more when
you give a when you give a percentage
consistently yeah and you know as weird
as it sounds
um you know we plan our impulses
yeah you know i mean we just it sounds
like it sounds really nerdy
you know but uh uh you know
being chaotic and out of control did not
cause us to build wealth
we were able to build wealth because we
planned yeah because we did it on
purpose
yeah and so uh you know so we do we plan
the nice things that we're gonna do now
we can set aside a chunk of money and go
okay
this money is almost in an envelope so
to speak it's not really but i mean
right this pile of money right here
is for an impulse yeah we're just gonna
blow it the blow envelope from there
we're going to go on a trip we're going
to buy a classic car we're going to do
whatever it is you want to do whatever
your thing is
and there's some enjoyment to that and
the same thing with generosity you can
have a
percentage of your generosity that's
very well thought through very much due
diligence some of it's just random acts
of kindness
yeah some of it's just walking up and
you know uh
buying a five thousand dollar car and
giving it to a single mom you know and
uh it changes
changes their life and it'll change
yours when you start doing that stuff
so there's a mix in here that makes this
whole thing good
uh and you know once you start writing
it all out there's just not as much room
as you thought there's gonna be no
no and i love what you said too i hope
folks you caught what dave said there's
planning that goes into generosity too
beyond the
paying for somebody's meal and starbucks
or you know the the fast food and then
it
starts into a chain but this idea of roi
you know return on investment in in
giving your money
it'll make you really intentional where
you give your money why you give your
money you want to see that maximized as
well
that's a good strategy the other thing
is it'll cause you to continue to do it
yes you won't have the let downs you
won't have to do it because sometimes
you can have a generosity let down
somebody doesn't do well with it yeah or
they you know
it's just it's a bad experience you know
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for joining us america ken
coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today you jump in we'll talk
about your life
and your money evan is with us in
raleigh-durham hi evan
welcome to the ramsey show hey dave and
ken how are you guys
great man what's up yeah so
my wife and i are homeowners and we are
currently at
81.3 loan to value rate
so we are almost able to get out of that
pmi
um and we were wondering if we should
dip into our six month emergency fund
just to get to that 80 percent to clear
that cost from our mortgage
what's your loan balance loan balance
is uh 211 thousand dollars 81.3
loan value yeah so three thousand
dollars gets you there
oh yeah i should have mentioned that
yeah yeah uh cost to get there
three thousand two hundred eighty eight
dollars okay so your
household income is what
uh it's in like 150 range 150.
okay and how much is in your emergency
fund
30 000 and you're debt-free but the
house
yes sir good okay excellent
uh you can do it if you want i mean it's
three to six months
as long as you don't go under three
months of expenses
you meet the guidelines um it's not that
much money you probably could just cash
flow it either one's okay
um have you have you checked with your
mortgage company to get if you check
with the mortgage company get the
procedure to get the pmi dropped
because you're probably gonna have to
buy an appraisal
um yeah i've gone through that process
and there will be no appraisal needed
there won't be so you write them a check
for 3200 the pmi is gone
yeah that seems to be it seems to be is
it in writing is that what they said
oh sorry um that definitely is it not
seems to be okay
all right i'm just making sure because i
don't want to tell you to do something
that's that might
be so yeah i mean if that if you've got
it all nailed down to that
uh it's not a big deal i mean the
different listen if you have an
emergency
the 27 000 won't cover you have an
emergency the 30 000 won't cover
yeah yeah i guess it's more of a thing
like if it was extrapolated out to a
bigger scenario
i guess your answer here would be like a
guidance for a
harder scenario there but yeah it would
be don't go below three months
three months of household expenses three
to six months is the guideline don't go
below that
to reduce debt or to do anything else
but if you want to use 3000 out of 30
with your 150 i think you're in line i
think you're well above three months
you can do that and if you want to
replenish it you want to have a little
beefier later you can do that because
you
can now have a lower house payment yeah
i like it evan do it
uh you're such a i mean you're thinking
this thing through so hard you could
hear the smoke coming out of your ears
and that's an awesome compliment to you
go ahead and do it and then replenish
the emergency fund
and you guys are going to feel so much
better about that tim in new york city
hi tim how are you
hey dave hey ken how you guys doing
today great what's up
i'm just one uh nothing much so uh i
wanted to know it's a two-part question
there's a human
and like less psychological element and
then there's also the financial part so
could i give you the numbers for what
our household income is and what our
debt is so far first
and then go into the question briefly
yeah
sure um so our household income is about
170 our total debt right now
is about 145 of 100 of which
is my uh partner student loans
are you married no we're okay we don't
have a household income then you have an
income she has an income
correct okay yeah okay so let's start
let's start again then let's start again
then
what is your income no problem my income
is about 85 000. okay and how much debt
do you have
i have about 22 000 worth of debt okay
and so your roommate has 143
000 or 123 000 worth of debt and 85 000
income yes okay and
yeah and how much savings do you have
i'm sorry how much savings do you have
i have about 10 000. okay and how much
does your roommate have saved
um she has about i don't know the exact
amount but somewhere between 120 and
130.
but that's part of my question okay so
my question my question is i want to
marry this girl
and i see us you know being together
indefinitely and we've been open with
each other talking about how we're going
to attack debt
we live with her parents now and we want
to pay this off so we can you know get a
house in the near future as quickly as
possible
um so we've been transparent about a lot
of things and
i wanted to ask you so the money that
she has saved is from a settlement she
got from a medical condition
that happened through a surgery and
something like that
and she's very reluctant to part ways
with any
like significant portion of it to pay
down her student loan debt
um so i just wanted to get both of your
opinions as to
did she recover did she recover from the
medical problem
um so it's a chronic it's became a
chronic nerve condition
that is long-term and can become acute
you know if something bad were to happen
or
if you know you know so what does she
spend on the chronic
condition per year um
right now between medication and therapy
maybe around
uh ten thousand okay
a little less okay a little less all
right so if
if the amount that she spends on her
condition doubles
she could still do that easily if she
was debt-free and didn't have any money
correct okay
all right well here's the thing you
don't get to decide what other people do
with their money unless you're married
to them
and then we work on our plan together
so i'm going to fast forward in the
conversation and pretend that you're
married
but don't do this unless you're married
get the advice okay because it's bad
advice
it's bad advice when you're not married
okay she should not pay any of your debt
you should not pay any of her debt
unless there is a
marriage certificate because it's
dangerous
correct okay so if if she called me
i would understand her pain
uh uh be empathetic with her pain listen
to her
and highly encourage her to write a
check today and be debt-free
okay and then take the freedom that
she's got with an 85 000
income and begin to rebuild her
emergency fund
uh i would tell you to take 9 000 of
your 10
and put it on your 22 reducing it
to then uh what 11
to 13 and then you're going to pay that
off very very quickly out of your 85
because you're going to be concentrating
on it
and so probably by the time you get your
marriage your wedding date set and
arranged
you both could be debt-free and building
your emergency funds which will put you
in a phenomenal position
to begin as a married couple to save to
buy a house later
great and that's the shortest distance
between where you are
and wealth the shortest distance between
where you are as a married couple
and financial peace in achieving your
goals
thank you and if you were my kids and
you sat down at my kitchen table
which you're both younger than my kids
and so i would tell you to do exactly
that same thing and i've told i don't
know
hundreds of thousands of people just
like you to the exact same thing in the
last 30 years on this show
yep tim i would just say on the
psychology of this to the best of your
ability sit down with your girlfriend
and see help her see what dave just
explained that she writes a check
today she pays off her debt and between
her
income and health care and the ability
to be free to save
she's not going to be in a financial
deficit
even with the chronic health condition
but she's got to see that you got to
help her get there
you can't tell her you have to help show
her that's the psychology there where
she gets to the point where she goes oh
okay that's great and she's got to get
free of that fear yeah you're right
if you if now let's change the scenario
just for a minute the reason i was
asking all these questions
because it does change the answer
actually in this one let's say she makes
eighty five thousand has 123 thousand
dollars in debt 130 000
in savings and i asked the question what
was the ongoing cost of her chronic
illness
and it's 50 000 a year now we're
probably not doing this
yeah i'm probably going to leave that
money sitting there and start to work on
the student loans out of my income
while i work through these chronic
things because that 130 000 is there to
take care of her medical needs first and
foremost that's right
at 10 000 or 20 000 it's not a big
problem mathematically
at 50 or 60 000 it starts to be a
[Music]
problem
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture today matthew 10 16. look
i'm sending you out
as sheep among wolves so be as shrewd
as snakes and harmless as doves
charles spurgeon said wisdom is the
right
use of knowledge yeah
i'm afraid there are other uses of
knowledge that's true
well folks you've heard me talking about
the timeshare folks for years and
what a crummy product timeshares are how
horrible they are
america's legal largest legalized fraud
one attorney called it
if you're a current timeshare owner or
you're a former timeshare owner our team
is conducting some research a new survey
where we want your thoughts
and your opinions on your experience
with time shares
if you want to take this quick survey
text time share
233 789
text time share one word two three three
seven eight nine
takes just a minute to take the survey
we really need your help
if you've ever owned or currently on a
time share please let us know
also we are going to be doing another
show on timeshares and if you have
had a bad experience with the windhams
of the world
the west gates of the world the diamonds
of the world
the timeshare companies that are out
there if you want to talk about your
experience with them
in the sales process in the trying to
get out the exiting process
or in just dealing with them by and
large trying to actually use your points
and oh my god lord help you if you want
to talk about it
we want to hear from you and we want you
to give you the opportunity to tell
america about what happened with you
so uh email us at daveonair
at ramseysolutions.com daveonair
at ramseysolutions.com
and just put time share in the subject
line and put a little bit about your
story
and a contact point and kelly will get
back with you and we will make you a
part of one of our upcoming shows
exposing
the fraud that is timeshare the horrible
horrible product that is timeshare we
want to let
all of you guys know not to go in the
tiger cage
don't pet the tiger it's like
whack-a-mole hour
they give a story and you just whack the
time share company it's pretty fun
pretty entertaining
that's yeah so even if you haven't had
bad experience this is must must listen
radio
it works out it's kind of fun no you
enjoy it thoroughly
i thoroughly enjoy it because you know
well here's for good reason though
here's the thing first i've been
working for 30 years helping people get
out of debt and build wealth
and there's like five or six really
horrible things you can do with money
that hold people back
and have really messed them over and uh
you know payday lenders
credit cards obviously student loan debt
whole life insurance uh leasing a car
uh and time shares and they all fall in
the same boat
but time shares is right it's it's the
scum er of the scummy
it's right down there with the payday
lender guys i mean they are screwing
people and they know it
yeah because the carly skies are just
like it's a bad deal
right right and the whole life guys
they're either
dumb and don't know it's a bad deal or
they're crooks and they know it's a bad
deal but either way there's a horrible
product that's right
but anyway you know you get into these
things but these guys i mean
if you sell time shares you know you're
screwing people yeah you just know you
are
you just don't care and it's how you
make your living yep and so
you know don't be scummy don't sell
timeshares whoa
there you go i love it this is how it
happens
that works good all right here we go
monica is in tampa florida hi monica how
are you
i'm good dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up in your world
um so i am a second year medical student
and i was wondering if you could help me
figure out what
to do with some extra money that my
husband and i have
um we're expecting uh baby number two
in august so yeah
and uh have saved about fifty thousand
dollars so far
and and by the time august and august
rolls around we'll have
probably around fifty five thousand cool
um and i was just
wondering whether once you know once she
arrives and everything's okay
um if we should put aside money for
tuition for the year which would be
thirty four thousand dollars
um and then just you know work the baby
steps
as normal from there or if we should put
a portion towards paying off my
husband's student loans which are
17 000 uh dollars left on that
um and then paying for the first
semester so
if you did that can you cash flow the
rest
yeah so we would have a little bit to go
i think uh like
five to seven thousand yeah but if you
don't have the student loan payments can
you cash flow the rest of it
um yeah i mean yeah that would free some
up
our daycare expenses are going to also
increase from
9.50 up to 2 000 a month so
you know paying off the student loans
would give us some more
uh breathing room let me try this let's
try that let's try it this way
so the 34 000 pays
medical school tuition for one year yeah
and you have how many years left you
said your second year does that finish
it
no no so it's a four-year program so i
have three more left which is a hundred
and
two thousand dollars more to go okay
and your husband makes how much
uh he taxable income is a hundred and
five thousand
okay all right so here's what i want you
to once you lay out your budget
and my you're not going to quit medical
school
okay you're going to finish and so if we
uh
if we use this money to pay off his
student loans and you come up short that
means you're going to borrow student
loans right
yeah exactly so that's just trading
pockets from one student loan to another
that's
kind of useless so goal one
uh i'm going to go with a hippocratic
oath okay do no more harm
okay okay
let's start with that as our as our
guideline and say
goal number one is finish med school
with no more new debt
okay if you can find money beyond that
then pay off his loans but you got 55 of
102 and 105 000
income to find the other 47.
to finish debt free right and you got
three years to do that so yeah i think
you could finish
that i think you could finish med school
with no more debt if we use the 55
towards your med school right
okay yeah yeah i think i think we we
could yeah
yeah and that's just saying job one is
cash flow
med school job two
if you find money beyond that let's go
ahead and get out of that
okay but it serves no purpose to pay off
his student loans and you turn around
take out student loans equal to that
exact amount
yeah you swap you just swap pockets
you're doing so good exactly he's got
105 you're gonna come out of med school
y'all are gonna be making 350 000
between you
ding ding girl y'all are killing it i'm
so proud of you hopefully
trying to not be a broke doctor well
you're not gonna be broke doctor if you
keep
thinking like you're thinking and asking
questions like you're asking
i'm so proud i mean you really are doing
great so yeah let's try to do something
very very weird and cash flow the
balance of med school i think you guys
can budget tight and pull that off
okay and then i do i have you know
because we did have to take out
loans for my first year and undergrad
loan
but those are all in deferment so
there's not right anything
so you come out of school and you know
you'll do residency first and you make
what 50 grand probably
yeah roughly yeah and then you finish
your residency and so your income's
going to go to 155
plus when you come out of school and you
guys will begin to attack
his loans and your loans at that point
and then when you finish
residency and you know become the
official md
then of course things are going to go
zoom zoom then you're just going to
clean up real fast you'll just sweep out
the corners and go
yeah and this game on yeah
congratulations monica
you guys are going to do this stay the
course keep your head down
this is uh this is sacrificing now so
that later
you don't have to sacrifice as much i
mean you can just crush this thing
it's very exciting this is two doctors
we've talked to today that
that are gonna be uh way ahead of the
game and uh boy it's nice to hear that
yeah working real hard not be broke
doctors right
because they're everywhere yeah way to
go monica good job
very good job excellent excellent work
love it
very fun ken good show thank you sir and
coleman ramsey personality my co-host
today james childs is our producer kelly
daniels our associate producer and phone
screener
i'm dave ramsey your host we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ jesus
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of
ramsay advice in their life let them
know about the ramsey call of the day
podcast it's a quick hit of advice about
life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
you